yannick est de retour sur les lieux de
l'accident qui dans la nuit du 12 au 13
janvier dernier aurait pu lui coûter la
vie il cherche à comprendre pourquoi il
a perdu le contrôle de son véhicule qui
s'est ensuite encastrée dans cette
maison cet accident n'aura pas fait de
blessé grave heureusement mais yannick
pointe du doigt ce canal obstrué dont
l'eau déborde sur la chaussée c'est pour
lui la principale cause de sa perte de
contrôle
il réfléchit à introduire une action en
justice il n'avait pas plu du tout la
route était sèche et je me suis fait
surprendre
du coup je pense que j'ai peut-être mis
un coup de frein je sais pas mais en
fait il se trouve que au moment je suis
passé sur le chemin de l'eau la voiture
est partie là du coup j'ai glissé après
je me sens casque dans la maison je me
souviens pas exactement de ce qui s'est
passé vraiment mais je suis arrivé
jusqu'au niveau de la maison yannick n'a
pas été la seule victime comme le
montrent ces images qui circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux
si le curage des caniveaux appartient à
la ville de fort de france
l'entretien de la rocade est du ressort
de la collectivité territoriale des
travaux devraient être lancés d'ici
cette semaine la première phase
consistera à des vidéos ici nous allons
au niveau de l'axé un livre bien sûr en
concertation avec les livres eux réalisé
un ouvrage qui va ramener les autres
dans le fossé bétonné que vous voyez au
quai du mur ces eaux seront ensuite
rejetée dans le virage 3 heures qui se
trouve au niveau de la passerelle
piétonne
métalliques il faudra casser et coisy
voilà et mais nous prenons des
dispositions pour assurer aux riverains
l'accès à l'eau résiliation dans un
second temps les ingénieurs de la ctm
devront rechercher les ouvrages qui
permet d'évacuer les eaux usées et qui
passe sous la rocade
nous avons engagé en 2018 des travaux
pour le curage de cet ouvrage qui est
totalement en juillet mais nous sommes
retrouvés face à un conglomérat de
déchets de toutes sortes nous avons
trouvé des sacs poubelles remplis des
pièces automobiles usagées comme des
échappements des amortisseurs développe
moteur nous allons tenter par des
fouilles de retrouver les ouvrages et de
tiré par le bas ces déchets pour pouvoir
déboucher cet ouvrage igo bien sûr la
présence d'eau sur la chaussée larron
glissante si pour cela qu'il est
important de lever le pied et de
respecter la signalisation sur cette
portion de route